oh man sick studies the acoustics of
spaces often large public spaces that is
reverberation sound propagates through
the air in a spherical pattern it
weakens over distance when it hits walls
corners or ceilings it's deflected six
company hollow plot has developed what
it calls game-changing 3d audio
technology it employs lots of small
loudspeakers not just a few large ones
and the system can direct sound to
specific points in space conventional
sound reverberates like this
thus the Kouga protocol the propagation
is spherical as with any source of sound
here under these domes the effect is
extreme the sound goes up and bounces
back down again that causes a weird
acoustic effect that's really
off-putting for both speakers and
listeners
there's always an echo
the new sound system by contrast can be
controlled exactly not just made louder
or quieter but also directed to a
certain part of the room after six years
of development holo plot is now ready to
go into series production companies from
all over the world have shown interest
including conference centers cinemas and
nightclubs
zix partner helmet Ellis is a sound
engineer he developed the new technology
and was granted a patent his aim was to
produce clean sound without any echo
effect no matter how big the room which
is good when my large place on the
normal loudspeakers radiates the sound
in all directions so the room determines
the quality of the sound our idea was to
direct the sound only at those listening
and not at the walls or ceiling Clifton
and Hamish know more echo effect in
large spaces in theory you could have
announcements and up to 16 languages
side-by-side each completely clear to
the targeted listener here they're only
testing three it was some words dropped
by chance that little by little espana
mogul is fortune me my jota my brownie
looks losses on your show at Christmas
bonus each is a milestone how thinkin's
is a heat we would have sex muna
no I scoped out how many loudspeakers
does he have here we asked
6450 lo que so sixty-four loudspeakers
and does each one have a different
function comes even though they emit all
signals but at different times and in
some cases different amplitudes so the
technology we have developed allows us
to precisely target different areas over
50 60 80 s 100 meters away and on that
way we have pretty much constant volume
in hannover at this year's cbut the
world's largest technology trade fair
zik showed visitors how the german
railway plans to implement his company's
audio system initial tests at
Frankfurt's main station were success
the idea is that travelers are able to
hear announcements as clearly as if they
were standing right by the loudspeaker
one area would be in German another in
English minor Damas
in this area you hear only English
smoking is not permitted in this area of
the station
the visitors are impressed Buddha meets
a fine oh my god I would really welcome
this you get all these announcements at
train stations but can't understand them
and you don't know if they apply to you
or not I think this way we'd be much
better informed than from you look and
holla plot isn't only focusing on
getting rid of unwanted echoes the
company also plans to one day reproduce
the sound of famous concert halls for
public spaces and for homes
[Music]